Nhân dịp kiến nạn tám i năm 2020, tổ miếng thứ trụ thích nước tổ lâm đã gửi thử trước mừng học viện luật quân.
Chong thứ, tổ miếng thứ biểu dương những thành tích đặc biệt xuất sắc của học viện trong tám i năm 2020,
trên đấu và chính thành. Đông thời bây giờ tính tưởng, học viện sẽ tiếp tục phát đi chuyển thấu anh hôm,
nột phá phát triển giáo dục đạo tạo, khoa học công nghệ, đối mới sáng tạo và chuyển đối số.
Rất phần xây dựng quân đội nhân dân cách mà chính quyết, tình về diện đại bảo vệ vững chắc tổ quốc trong giải đạn cách mạng mới.
Phát biểu tại buổi lẽ, đại dự phán phát dăng, y vien bộ chính trị, bỏ thủ tưởng chính phủ bộ trường bộ cuốc phòng,
biểu dương những thành tích đặc bó của các kỹ gệ cán bộ dàng viên, học viên, nhân viên,
chiến sĩ học viện luật quân trong xuất tám i năm qua, đại dựng dựng dựng cộ học viện tiếp tục lộ mới mạnh mẽ sáo dục đạo tạo.
Bệ mạnh những cứu pho học chuyển đối số, ở dụng pho công nghệ và chính tệ nhân tạo và gặn dầy.
Sây dựng lộ mù cán bộ giảng viên, chiến lượng cao, phần đầu đến năm 2018,
sây dựng học viện luật quân thông viên, giải đại.
Trời thành một trong những trung tâm đạo tạo và những cứu pho, quân sự hàng đầu của cả nước và khu vực.
Đại tựng pho ngăn nhé mạnh.
Tức tục đối mới nổi dông, chiến trình đạo tạo theo dưới pho, giải đại.
Sát thực hiện, tệ mạnh chuyển đối số, ứng dụng công nghệ số và chính tệ nhân tạo trong đạo dục đạo.
Hông viện và chủ động nghiêm cứu, dựng báo và tham yêu với quân người chúng ngân bộ cũng phong.
Đên nghệ thuật quân sự, phần đầu đến năm 2018, sây dựng học viện luật quân thông viên, giải đại.
Đến năm 2019, trở thành nhà trường thông viên, giải đại.
Tốt đầu về đạo tạo và những cứu pho quân sự của cả nước và trong khu vực.
Dịm này, học viện luật quân thinh dự được năng, nhà nước chào tạo nguyên triân báo về thuốc khách nhất.
Vinh nhận những đạo có góc đặt biệt suất chẳng giáo dục đạo tạo.
Nhưng cứu pho, và sự nghiệp sây dựng báo về thuốc.